Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 12. Ausgabe. Und nachdem wir ja hier auch immer viele Metathemen besprechen und uns grundsätzlich um die Organisation der Wissenschaft kümmern, wollen wir heute auch nochmal ein bisschen konkreter in konkrete wissenschaftliche Arbeit einsteigen und ein Thema aufgreifen, was auch eine – also abgesehen davon, dass natürlich jede Wissenschaft eine gesellschaftliche Bedeutung hat – heute ein Thema angehen, was auch sehr in der Diskussion ist und wo ich auch so den Eindruck habe, dass das schon auch verstanden wurde, welche Bedeutung es gerade hat. Das kann man ja nicht von allen Wissenschaftstrends behaupten. Konkret soll es gehen um Energie bzw. die Forschung an der Energie und um darüber zu sprechen begrüße ich Ferdi Schüth, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo Herr Pritlove.
Herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist. Sie sind Chemiker und das auch schon eine ganze Weile und mittlerweile Direktor des Max-Planck-Instituts für Kohlenforschung heißt das oder?
Kohlenforschung heißt es, aber das ist ein Markennamen. Kohlenforschung macht da eigentlich seit vielen Jahren niemand mehr. Wir übersetzen aber auch nicht mal den Namen mehr ins Englische, so dass wir wenn wir international unterwegs sind, das Institut einfach als Institut für Kohlenforschung bekannt ist. Und viele gar nicht wissen, was Kohlenforschung bedeutet.
Das ist ja in Mülheim.
Existiert seit 1913, also von daher hat das eine lange Historie. 1913/14 war Kohle eben ein großes Thema im Ruhrgebiet und wir alle wissen, dass das Ruhrgebiet den Strukturwandel mittlerweile fast komplett durchlaufen hat. Kohle ist nicht mehr so hoch auf dem Radarschirm.
Das heißt ursprünglich ging es tatsächlich erst mal so um den Abbau von Kohle bzw. die Auswertung?
Nein. Es ging eigentlich darum, die Kohle intelligenter zu nutzen als durch Verbrennung. Also das war selbst zu der Zeit damals schon auf dem Radar, dass man vielleicht geschickter mit Kohle umgehen könnte, als sie einfach zu verbrennen. Und der erste Direktor des Instituts war Franz Fischer, der – das mögen viele der Hörer vielleicht wissen oder zumindest den Namen gehört haben – der hat den Fischer-Dropsch-Prozess zusammen mit seinem Mitarbeiter Hans Dropsch erfunden. Eines der entscheidenden Verfahren, um im Prinzip aus jeder kohlenstoffhaltigen Rohstoffquelle einen sehr hochwertigen Dieselkraftstoff herzustellen. Da kann man Kohle nehmen, da kann man Biomasse nehmen, da kann man Erdgas nehmen. Aus all dem kann Dieselkraftstoff herstellen oder ein Kohlenwasserstoffgemisch, was wie ein Dieselkraftstoff nutzbar ist, mit einer extrem hohen Qualität.
Das wurde in den 20er Jahren in diesem Institut entwickelt, also tatsächlich jenseits der Verbrennung von Kohle.
Fand das dann auch schon Anwendung?
Ja. Ja das wurde, war natürlich im dritten Reich Teil der Autarkiebestrebungen, Ölvorräte gab es nicht, also ist man an die Kohle ran gegangen. Und da gab es eigentlich zwei Verfahren, um aus Kohle Flüssigkraftstoffe zu machen. Das sogenannte Bergiusverfahren und das Fischer-Dropsch-Verfahren. Da hat es also tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe von Anlagen gegeben. Später dann war eigentlich Südafrika das wesentliche Land, was das Verfahren genutzt hat. Da lag dann auch die Technologieführerschaft, kann man tatsächlich sagen. Auch aus offensichtlichen Gründen, Apartheid, Isolation, Rohstoffknappheit in Bezug auf Ölquellen, aber viel Kohle. Und damit wurde eben Fischer-Dropsch-Kraftstoff in Südafrika hergestellt.
Mittlerweile ist es tatsächlich ein Verfahren, was immer mehr für auch die großen Ölmultis relevant wird. Eine der großen Anlagen steht jetzt in Katar, da wird aus Erdgas ein Kraftstoff hergestellt, den man dann vernünftig transportieren kann. In den Ölfeldern hat man oft das Problem, dass man mit dem Erdgas nicht so fürchterlich viel anfangen kann, weil es nicht gut transportierbar ist, wenn man keine Pipelines oder Schiffe hat. Und in diesen Fischer-Dropsch-Anlagen kann man eben dann einen Flüssigkraftstoff herstellen, der sehr hochwertig ist. Der hat keinen Schwefel mehr, weil man den sehr gut aufreinigen kann. Der wird also teilweise zugemischt zu konventionellem Dieselkraftstoff sogar, um die Qualität zu verbessern. Also das ist die Historie des Instituts.
Qualität zu verbessern oder vielleicht dann auch die Umweltauflagen zu erfüllen.
Ja klar.
Schwefel ??? hoch ist.
Genau, man verdünnt im Prinzip mit einem schwefelfreien Fischer-Dropsch-Kraftstoff, um unter die Schwefelgrenzwerte zu kommen. Genauso ist das.
Das heißt, dieses Institut ist ja eigentlich von Vornherein ein Energieforschungsinstitut gewesen. Auch wenn es sich erst mal auf einen bestimmten Rohstoff konzentriert hat.
Naja das war 30 Jahre lang etwa ein Energieforschungsinstitut bis 1943 und dann hat es einen radikalen Themenwechsel eigentlich gegeben. Dann wurde jemand berufen, Karl Ziegler, der zu der Zeit eigentlich eine ganz esoterische Chemie durchführte. Der beschäftigte sich mit sogenannten organometallischen Verbindungen, also Verbindungen, wo eine direkte Bindung zwischen einem Metall und einem organischen Molekül vorliegt und da hat er eine ganze Reihe wirklich herausragender Entdeckungen gemacht. Die bekannteste ist die Ziegler-Polymerisation, wo man kleine Kohlenwasserstoffmoleküle Olefine zu Polymeren macht. Wenn Sie also heute eine Plastiktüte in der Hand haben oder einen Plastikeimer im Haushalt oder einen fast beliebigen Plastikgegenstand im Haushalt, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der über die Ziegler-Polymerisation hergestellt ist, verhältnismäßig groß.
Hat dem Institut, das ist patentiert worden Anfang der 50er Jahre, hat dem Institut, schwer zu schätzen, wie viel es zu heutigen Preisen wäre, aber wahrscheinlich insgesamt so eine Milliarde Euro zu heutigen Kursen Lizenzgebühren eingebracht und dem Ziegler den Nobelpreis. Das hatte aber mit Energieforschung in der Zeit relativ wenig zu tun. Und dann gab es einen erneuten Wechsel in den 90er Jahren, wo sich das Institut in Richtung Katalyse orientiert hat und die Katalyse, also die Beschleunigung von chemischen Reaktionen durch andere Stoffe, die sich in erster Näherung mal nicht verändern in der chemischen Reaktion, ist eigentlich eine Energietechnologie schon aus sich heraus, weil dadurch die chemischen Prozesse bei milderen Bedingungen ressourcenschonender, energieschonender verlaufen.
Sie kann aber viel breiter genutzt werden, eben um tatsächlich neuartige Energieträger herzustellen und naja wenn man zurückgeht an den Anfang der Geschichte auf Franz Fischer, der hat eben Katalysatoren für diesen Fischer-Dropsch-Prozess entwickelt. Also da schließt sich fast ein Kreis. Geht ein bisschen Back to the Roods. Ich habe in meiner Abteilung gerade eine Fischer-Dropsch-Testanlage aufgebaut. Also nach 100 Jahren...
Geht es wieder von vorne los.
Geht es wieder von vorne los. Hoffentlich auf einem höheren Niveau.
Seit wann sind Sie dann dort als Direktor tätig?
98 bin ich berufen worden, also 17 Jahre jetzt.
Was hat Sie denn selber zu dem Thema Chemie überhaupt gebracht?
Zur Chemie?
Ja oder sagen wir vielleicht überhaupt erst mal in die Wissenschaft. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das gleich mit Chemie angefangen hat.
Nein, das fing sofort mit Chemie an. Also ich war zwar immer interessiert an Naturphänomenen, aber wenn man disziplinär denkt, dann ging das sofort in Richtung Chemie und das lag an einem Freund in der 5. Klasse, der nach Silvester immer durch die Straßen zog, ausgebrannte Raketenhülsen und ähnliches suchte und die dann mit selbst gemischtem Schwarzpulver wieder fühlte und versuchte zum Fliegen zu bringen. Und dem habe ich mich angeschlossen und das war meine erste Berührung mit der Chemie, das hat mich nie wieder losgelassen. Meine Eltern haben das sehr unterstützt, die fanden das spannend, fanden, dass das Karriereperspektiven waren, die haben mir dann also irgendwann einen Chemiekasten geschenkt. Ich habe mir im Keller so ein kleines Labor eingerichtet.
War die Integrität des Heimathauses je gefährdet?
Naja gefährdet war sie wahrscheinlich schon zwischendurch mal, es ist aber nie was passiert, das steht noch das Haus. Aber dieser spielerische Experimentalzugang zur Chemie, der hat das Interesse ausgelöst und naja gut, nachher verändert sich das, nachher blickt man anders auf die Dinge, aber dieser Zugang fasziniert mich immer noch und ich mache so in regelmäßigen Abständen, sagen wir alle zwei Jahre, weil es eine große Arbeit, ein großer Aufwand ist, mache ich mit zwei Mitarbeitern eine große Experimentalshow in der Freilichtbühne bei uns in Mülheim. Da passen so 2.500 Leute rein und wenn das an einem guten Tag ist, wo das Wetter schön ist und es ein Wochenende ist, dann kommen auch in der Dimension Menschen und dann …
Auch Familien nehme ich an.
Klar, Schulen, Familien mit Kindern, also das ist schon eine große Show.
Ja da kann man auch schnell mal den nächsten Chemiker ???
Da kann man schnell, ja das zieht tatsächlich zumindest das erste Interesse mal auf die Chemie. Ob die Leute dann dabei bleiben, ist eine andere Frage, aber über diesen Zugang fasziniert man schon die jungen Menschen. Und am Ende, mir macht das immer noch unbändigen Spaß. Also das mach ich genauso viel für die Zuschauer, wie für mich selber und das geht den Mitarbeitern, die das mit mir machen genauso.
Ich bemerke das in letzter Zeit öfter, ich weiß nicht, ob ich nur nicht lange genug hingeschaut habe, aber in immer mehr Städten entstehen solche, ich sage mal, populären Wissenschaftszentren. Ich glaube, Wolfsburg, wie heißt das Phänon???, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, also so Orte, die quasi, ja weiß nicht, Museum beschreibt es nicht so richtig, nicht selten führen sie diesen Namen, wo es aber eben auch wirklich ganz aktiv darum geht, grundlegende wissenschaftliche Zusammenhänge überhaupt erst mal deutlich zu machen auf allen möglichen Feldern. Ich finde das eigentlich einen sehr angenehmen Trend und ich denke, an der Stelle steht wahrscheinlich auch die Wissenschaft so ein bisschen in der Pflicht, so was auch zu unterstützen.
Ja klar. Also die harten Naturwissenschaften sind ja in der Regel nicht die erste Wahl der Schülerinnen und Schüler, wenn es darum geht, Leistungskurse zu wählen oder später auch ein Studienfach zu wählen. Da steht anderes eher im Vordergrund. Und wenn es einem gelingt, mit solchen Mechanismen die jungen Leute zu faszinieren und zumindest an das Thema spielerisch heranzuführen, dann ist das auf jeden Fall was, was der Wissenschaft nutzt, was aber glaube ich auch der Volkswirtschaft in Deutschland und Europa nützt. Denn ich glaube schon, dass wir einen Wissensgesellschaft sind und dieser Teil der Wissenschaft, die harten Naturwissenschaften, sind eine wichtige Basis unserer Wirtschaft und letztlich unserer Zivilisation des Lebens, so wie wir es heute führen.
Und die Museen, die immer interaktiver werden, helfen enorm und ich kann mich erinnern, mich hat als Kind das Deutsche Museum in München fasziniert. Das war ja das erste, wo es zumindest so diesen Ansatz gab. Das hat man vor 40-50 Jahren natürlich noch ein bisschen anders gemacht. Da gab es die Schaukästen, da drückte man auf einen Knopf und dann passierte eine Reaktion in diesem Schaukasten, aber zumindest konnte man schon mal den Knopf drücken, was in einem Museum, wo nur Bilder hängen, ja nicht der Fall ist. Und die Dinge sind immer interaktiver geworden. Es gibt Mitmachlabors an vielen Universitäten, Schülerlabors an vielen Universitäten, wo eben 10-Jährige, 12-Jährige in die Institute, in die Unis, in die Museen kommen und selber was machen dürfen. In unserem Institut gibt es die Schülerpraktika, es gibt die Girls-Days, es gibt den Türöffner-Tag der Sendung mit der Maus, wo also im Prinzip der WDR versucht, Schüler in Unternehmen oder Institute reinzubringen. Da gibt es also ganz viele Aktivitäten, ich finde die alle enorm wichtig.
Ändert das auch schon was? Lässt sich das schon bemerken? Das sind ja so ein bisschen Trends der letzten 10 Jahre, das ist ja noch nicht ganz eine Karriere.
Naja es ist immer noch nicht so, dass die Überzahl, die Mehrzahl der Schülerinnen und Schüler, Abiturienten in die Naturwissenschaften geht. Das kann man auch wahrscheinlich nicht erwarten. Aber das Interesse an Naturwissenschaften das hat glaube ich durchaus zugenommen, das würde ich schon so sehen. Sicherlich auch durch Fernsehsendungen und andere Medien, wo ja Wissenssendungen zumindest einen größeren Platz haben, als das vielleicht vor 30 Jahren der Fall war. Für die Chemie kann man das sehr klar sagen, als ich Chemie studiert habe in den 80er Jahren, da tendierte man eher dazu, das zu verschweigen auf einer Party, dass man Chemiker war, weil man ja tendenziell der böse Mensch war, der die Flüsse verschmutzte, die Atmosphäre verschmutzte. Die Chemie war wirklich zu der Zeit ein Problem verursacht. Können Sie sich vielleicht erinnern.
Mittlerweile hat sich das Image verändert. Die Chemie wird durchaus wie andere Wissenschaften auch, aber gerade da kann man es besonders festmachen, in vielen Bereichen eher als Problemlöser gesehen, auch im Energiebereich im übrigen. Und wenn sie nicht als Problemlöser gesehen wird, dann hat sich die Haltung zumindest von feindlicher Ablehnung, ich nenne das immer freundliches Interesse, verschoben, was ja schon mal was ist. Man kann sicher noch ein Stückchen weiterkommen, aber im Vergleich zu wirklich feindlicher Ablehnung ist freundliches Desinteresse schon ganz okay.
Ja die dunklen Zeiten sind da so ein bisschen zurückgelegt worden. So in den 70/80er Jahren mit den Verschmutzungen der Flüsse usw. das war ja wirklich ein riesen Thema.
Da haben wir die Unfälle in Basel gehabt, wo teilweise schlecht reagiert worden ist, die natürlich sowieso nicht passieren sollten, wo aber auch schlecht reagiert worden ist und das hat das Image wirklich ruiniert. Und das ist nicht mehr so, das ist zum Glück nicht mehr so und ich glaube auch, dass das Bild von der Chemie als Problemlöser ein durchaus zutreffendes ist. Gerade im Energiebereich, was Sie in der Anmoderation erwähnt haben, da gibt es eigentlich keine Technologie, die ohne wesentliche Komponenten aus der Chemie auskommt.
Es sind ja auch so Ihre Kernbeschäftigungsfelder gewesen in den letzten Jahren. Soweit ich es überblicke, haben Sie sich mit allen möglichen Formen der Energiespeicherung vor allem beschäftigt. Wasserstoffspeicherung, Biomasse. Warum erst mal? Wie kam es dazu? Ich meine, man kann ja alles mögliche verfolgen, wenn man jetzt im chemischen Bereich ist.
Ja klar, man kann alles mögliche verfolgen, als Max-Planck-Wissenschaftler hat man im Prinzip auch den Auftrag, zunächst mal Grundlagenforschung zu betreiben. Und die könnte man auf jedes beliebige Thema richten, da haben Sie völlig recht. Ich habe aber, wann habe ich das, also ich habe mich für das Thema Energie eigentlich immer schon interessiert. Mir ist aber zu Beginn der 2000er Jahre wirklich ja ganz deutlich bewusst geworden, dass die Frage der Energieversorgung unserer Zivilisation die Schlüsselfrage des 21. Jahrhunderts eigentlich sein wird. Wenn man sich klar macht, wie Länder wie China expandieren, Länder wie Indien, Südamerika, wo wirklich die Bevölkerung auch wächst und der Energieverbrauch pro Kopf im Moment auf einem relativ niedrigen Level liegt, wenn man sich das anschaut, dann wird einem klar, die Energieversorgung der Welt ist ein drängendes Problem. Wie gesagt, für mich das größte Problem des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Und habe dann, als ich mir die Chemie und die Beschäftigungsfelder der Chemie angeschaut habe, festgestellt, naja besonders intensiv bringt sich die Chemie nicht in diese Diskussion ein, obwohl sie eigentlich an jeder Ecke Beiträge leisten müsste und das auch tat, aber eben nicht dezidiert, um das Energiethema voranzubringen. Und das hat für mich dann dazu geführt, mich mit dem Thema intensiver zu beschäftigen, und wenn man grundlegende Fragen klären will, was mich als Max-Planck-Wissenschaftler natürlich immer noch sehr interessiert, dann kann man die auf eine esoterische Modellreaktion lenken oder man kann die Fragestellung an tatsächlich relevanten Reaktionen für die Herstellung von Energieträgern studieren. Und wenn man die Wahl hat, dann nehme ich doch lieber das Studium der Reaktionen, die auch wirklich gebraucht werden.
Fängt es nicht so ein bisschen mit Solarenergie an und war das nicht schon eigentlich ein hoch chemisches Thema?
Die Solarenergie ist insofern ein chemisches Thema, als die Materialien über chemische Prozesse hergestellt werden. Das reine Silicium, was man braucht, wird über einen relativ aufwendigen chemischen Prozess hergestellt, der prinzipiell aus der Halbleitertechnologie bekannt war. Das war ja vorgeschaltet eigentlich vor der großskaligen Einführung von Solarzellen. Aber eben dann übertragen wurde auf Fotovoltaik. Billiger gemacht werden musste, die Reinheitsanforderungen sind bei der Fotovoltaik eben nicht ganz so groß wie in der Chipindustrie. Die Kristalle, die man da nutzt, müssen keine Einkristalle??? sein, also in der Chipindustrie braucht man, um wirklich die Leistung zu erreichen, die man möchte in einem Laptop oder in einem Cellphone oder wo auch immer, braucht man einkristallines Silicium, das ist nicht dringend erforderlich in der Fotovoltaik.
Da sind die Effizienzen dann zwar ein bisschen größer, aber der Kostennachteil des einkristallinen Siliciums wird eben oft aufgewogen durch die – oder nicht aufgewogen durch die etwas verbesserte Effizienz der Solarzellen. Aber es sind chemische Themen ganz eindeutig.
Aber da war dann doch noch mehr zu holen, meinten Sie?
Das war eben nur eines der Felder. Und die Menschen in der Chemie, die sich mit dem Silicium beschäftigten, das war ein relativ kleiner Teil. Die organische Fotovoltaik, die jetzt sehr im Kommen ist, also polymere Solarzellen, Plastiksolarzellen, um es mal mit einem simplen Schlagwort zu belegen, das kam später, das kam nachgeschaltet, da steckt eigentlich noch viel mehr Chemie drin, als in den klassischen uns bekannten schwarzen oder dunkelblauen Silicium-Solarzellen. Heute gibt es ganz neue Generationen von Solarzellen, die sogenannten Perowskit-Solarzellen???, das ist Festkörperchemie par excellence, diese Systeme herzustellen, zu charakterisieren, zu optimieren.
Aber jenseits der Solarzellen gibt es eben noch beliebig viele weitere Themen. Sie haben es eben angesprochen, Nutzung von Biomasse. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie Biomasse, die ja eigentlich ein guter Energieträger ist, das wissen wir alle, wenn wir mal am Lagerfeuer gesessen haben, Biomasse hat eine hohe Energiedichte. Wenn wir die mit Erdöl vergleichen ist die chemisch was völlig anderes. Erdöl ist ein Molekül, was fast nur aus Kohlenstoff und Wasserstoff besteht, und wenn ich es nutzen will, kann ich es in der Regel direkt sofort verbrennen, destillieren, die Fraktion Benzin oder Diesel rausholen, die ich möchte, es direkt verbrennen. Und wenn ich es als chemischen Rohstoff nutzen will, dann muss ich Sauerstoffmoleküle typischerweise einführen in die Erdölmoleküle.
Biomasse hat über den Daumen für jedes Kohlenstoffatom fast auch ein Sauerstoffatom drin. Und der Sauerstoff stört in diesen hohen Konzentrationen. Das heißt, Biomasse muss ich erst mal vom Sauerstoff befreien oder weitgehend befreien, bevor ich die als Energieträger nutzen kann. Und da braucht man ganz selektive Verfahren, chemische Verfahren, um das zu schaffen, um diesen Sauerstoff gezielt aus dem Molekül rauszuholen, ohne dass man zu viel Energieinhalt des Moleküls verliert. Also das ist eine ganz fundamentale und eigentlich eine neue chemische Fragestellung, mit der man sich vorher nicht beschäftigt hat, weil das Herausholen von Sauerstoffmolekülen war für die chemische Industrie kaum von Interesse. Man war eigentlich eher daran interessiert, welche reinzubringen, um die Grundchemikalien herzustellen in dem Kohlenwasserstoff, den man aus dem Erdöl rausholte.
Batterietechnik... also wollen Sie da noch mal bleiben ja?
Nur noch mal ganz kurz nachfragen. Also wann fing das zum Beispiel jetzt an, nur um das mal so auch zeitlich zu verorten, wie neu das ist?
So was geht in Wellen. Also der eben schon zitierte Bergius hat sich auch mit Biomasse beschäftigt. Mit der hydrothermalen Karbonisierung. So hieß das, also unter Druck, unter Wassereinfluss aus Biomasse im Prinzip künstliche Kohle herzustellen, in Anführungsstrichen. Dann war es eine ganze Zeit mal relativ tot. Dann weiß man zumindest aus dem Fernsehen oder aus Berichten, nach dem Krieg gab es dann Holzvergaser im Auto, wo also Holz verschwelt wurde und so eine Art Pyrolyseöl als Treibstoff genutzt wurde. Dann wurde es wieder ruhig um die Biomasse, weil Erdöl in den 60er/Anfang der 70er Jahre einfach eine ganz billige ...
Das musste man einfach nur noch aus der Erde rausholen.
Das sprudelte im Prinzip, das war fertig, das waren qualitativ hochwertige Öle mit wenig Schwefel, die man zu der Zeit hatte. Das kostet nicht viel. In der Zeit war Biomasse uninteressant. Es gab dann ein Revival wieder in der Zeit der ersten Ölkrise, als die Araber die OPEC den Hahn zumindest teilweise zudrehte. Dann hat man sich wieder damit beschäftigt, was können wir eigentlich mit Biomasse machen. Und dann ging es eigentlich richtig stark los so Anfang der 2000er kann man auch sagen, als wir die Biokraftstoffdirektiven in der EU hatten, also Pflichtbeimischung von Biokraftstoffen zu Benzin und Diesel. Da hat man dann zunächst die Biokraftstoffe der ersten Generation genommen, die man also aus den letztlich Früchten von Pflanzen gewinnt. Ölfrüchte oder auch Weizen, Soja waren ja die Rohstoffe.
Naja und dann ist man a) schnell in der ethischen Diskussion, Teller oder Tank, b) stellte sich heraus, wenn man CO2-Emisionen mindern möchte, dann sind viele dieser Biokraftstoffe der ersten Generation eben auch nicht wirklich die optimalen. Da gibt es je nach Anbaubedingung Biokraftstoffe, die haben einen größeren CO2-Fußabdruck als den Kraftstoff, den man aus Kohle herstellen würde. Das ist nicht immer so, aber das kann so sein. Und man ist dann also zu dem Schluss gekommen, zum einen müssen wir Verfahren entwickeln, mit denen wir CO2 ärmer Biomasse in Energie verwandeln können, zum anderen sollten wir davon weggehen, nur die Früchte der Pflanzen zu nutzen, sondern die gesamte Pflanzenbiomasse zu nutzen. Also Holzstiele, Stängel, Stroh, Blätter, alles was da ist, die sogenannte Lignocellulose??? und damit tut sich dann wieder ein neuer Bereich an chemischen Herausforderungen auf.
Also die Früchte, die sind einfach zu nutzen. Die können wir ja auch essen. Die enthalten, wenn wir Getreide nehmen, enthalten die Zuckermoleküle, an denen wir interessiert sind, in Form von Stärke. Und da kann unser Körper gut mit umgehen. Wenn wir auf Holz kauen, können wir lange kaufen, das wird nicht süß. Also den Zucker, der im Holz ist, an den kommen wir mit unserem Metabolismus nicht ran und auch die meisten anderen Organismen haben Schwierigkeiten damit. Also dieses komplexe Biomolekül Lignocellulose, was letztlich der Grundbestandteil vom Holz ist, aufzuschließen, braucht man wieder ganz neue chemische Verfahren. Also es gab immer dieses Wechselspiel an neuen chemischen Verfahren und neuen Herausforderungen, die sich gegenseitig eigentlich immer auf ein höheres Niveau gebracht haben. Man kann also nicht sagen, das fing an irgendeinem Punkt an, sondern das waren eigentlich Wellen, die wir gesehen haben.
Aber man kann sagen, dass es so seit gut 15 Jahren …
So über den Daumen, sagen wir so 15-20 Jahre.
... einer neuen Welle ist sozusagen.
Ja. Das würde ich schon, also bei der Biomasse. Mit einem starken Anstieg eher in den letzten 10 Jahren würde ich sagen. Da sind viele auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen. Aber es gibt eben zahlreiche weitere Themen. Batterien sind rein chemische Fragestellungen. Gut, materialwissenschaftliche auch, aber da steckt eben auch viel Chemie drin. Wenn wir irgendwann mal mit einem Batterieauto 600 Kilometer fahren wollen – Fußnote, möglicherweise muss man gar nicht mit einem Auto 600 Kilometer fahren, sondern muss das Verkehrssystem anpassen. Aber nehmen wir mal an, wir versuchen einfach das, was wir jetzt an Mobilität haben, 30 Jahre in die Zukunft zu transplantieren. Dann würden wir eben mit dem Auto 600 Kilometer fahren wollen. Mit heutigen Batterien ist das illusorisch, wenn man auch noch ein bisschen Gepäck und einige Menschen mitnehmen will.
Und da braucht man neue Ansätze für Batterietechnologie, die diese Speicherdichten aufbringen, mit denen man Energie so eng in eine Batterie packen kann, so dicht in eine Batterie packen, dass man es eben schafft, diese 500-600 Kilometer zu fahren.
Gefühlt geht es ja so bei den Batterien nicht voran, das stimmt natürlich nicht, aber wenn man sich jetzt gerade in der Computertechnik, wo ja die Batterien auch eine große Rolle spielen, das so anschaut, so alles wird immer so unglaublich rasant schneller, ???Law, alles verdoppelt sich innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Nur eben die Energiespeicher können nicht in demselben Maße mithalten.
Das ist eine Wahrnehmung.
Ja das ist eine Wahrnehmung, und deswegen wollte ich die mal hinterfragen.
Also nehmen Sie mal Ihren Laptop von vor 10 Jahren. Der war schwer, der wog 5 Kilo. Also meinen Laptop, den ich vor 10 Jahren hatte, der hatte ungefähr 5 Kilo würde ich sagen. Und da hatte die Batterie eine Laufzeit von vielleicht zwei Stunden. Heute wiegt mein Laptop 1,6 Kilo, der kann mehr, natürlich hat auch die Hardware und Software außerhalb der Batterie dazu beigetragen und die Batterie läuft, wenn sie gut ist, sechs Stunden. Das ist eine dramatische Änderung, die nehmen wir nicht wahr, weil das Ding halt immer noch ein Laptop ist. Aber wie gesagt, nehmen Sie mal Ihren Laptop von vor 10 Jahren und wiegen Sie den gegen Ihren heutigen und das war ein großer Teil Batterie.
Und die Speicherdichte einer Batterie um Faktor 3 zu erhöhen ist der Schritt zu der 600 Kilometer Reichweite des Autos. Also heute schafft man knapp 200 Wattstunden pro Kilogramm bei einer Batterie, wenn man 600 Wattstunden hätte könnte man da wahrscheinlich die 500-600 Kilometer Reichweite erreichen.
Und wie weit sind wir davon entfernt?
Naja um Faktor 3. Es gibt eine Roadmap, es gibt potenzielle Batterietechnologien, die das könnten. Es gibt heute schon Batterien, die ungefähr in diese Speicherdichtedimension reinkommen, sogenannten Metallluftbatterien, Zinkluftbatterien werden zum Beispiel in Hörgeräten eingesetzt. Dann müssen die in relativ wenig Gewicht, weil die ja im Hörgerät im Ohr mit drinsitzen, relativ lange halten und den Energieinhalt haben. Das sind aber Einwegbatterien, die können Sie nicht wieder aufladen. Wenn man es schaffte, wiederaufladbare Metallluftbatterien herzustellen und es gibt so erste Versuche, dann schafft man schon mal 3-5 Zyklen oder so, vielleicht auch nochmal ein paar mehr. Aber mit Verlusten pro Zyklus beim Wiederaufladen.
Wenn man solche Batterien wiederaufladbar gestalten könnte, dann wäre man eigentlich da. Aber die Herausforderung ist eine große. Ich vergleiche das, weil die Batterietechnologie, was dann genau in so einer Batterie ist, ist den meisten nicht so bewusst, aber ich vergleiche es mit einem Beispiel, was man sich vielleicht besser vorstellen kann. Die Reaktion eines Metalls mit Luft, die kennen wir alle von Eisen. Wenn das an der Luft ist, rostet das. Und das Wiederaufladen einer Batterie ist im Prinzip nichts anderes, als diesen Reaktionsvorgang mit Luft rückgängig zu machen, durch Zuführung von elektrischer Energie. Was man also schaffen müsste wäre, so ein Eisenstück, so ein verrostetes Eisenstück als Elektrode zu schalten, Spannung darauf zu geben und dann verschwindet der Rost und es liegt da wieder ein strahlendes, glänzendes Eisenstück.
Das kann sich glaube ich jeder vorstellen, dass das eine echte Herausforderung ist. Das ist nicht wirklich einfach. Und das ist im Prinzip die Herausforderung, vor der man steht, eine wiederaufladbare Metallluftbatterie zu produzieren. Wie gesagt, ich bin überzeugt davon, das wird man schaffen, aber da werden wohl noch ein paar wahrscheinlich eher Jahrzehnte Forschung brauchen.
Es gibt ja wirklich sehr viele Kandidaten für neue Batteriesysteme, weil ja auch die Anforderungen sehr unterschiedlich sind, in Autos ist es vor allem die Energiemenge, die innerhalb kürzester Zeit abgerufen muss. Sehr großen Computer hat nicht in demselben Maße den Hunger sofort, aber hätte es halt gerne möglichst lang. Wie dynamisch ist denn dieser Forschungsbereich derzeit. Wie viele neue – also ich habe so den Eindruck, es wird irgendwie alle zwei Jahre ein komplett neues Verfahren genannt, was auf den Tisch kommt. Es gibt einem ja auch ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass dieser Bereich einfach enorm unterforscht ist oder war.
Der war sicherlich unterforscht. Batterieentwicklung galt lange als nicht besonders heißes wissenschaftliches Feld. Also bis in die 90er Jahre. Naja wofür brauchte man Batterien in der allgemeinen Wahrnehmung.
Taschenlampe.
Ja das ist das was einem einfällt. Dann hatte man dann die Zellen.
Radios.
Genau, aber da waren die Anforderungen ja verhältnismäßig gering. Und dann kamen die Laptops auf und es kamen Cellphones auf, Mobiltelefone auf, das waren eigentlich die beiden großen Treiber für massenhaften breiten Einsatz von Batterietechnologien, wobei die Batterien aufladbar sein mussten. Niemand würde ein Handy oder einen Laptop mit einer Einwegbatterie betreiben wollen. Das hat für Europa natürlich oder unglücklicherweise bedeutet, dass wir zumindest zeitweise in dieser Entwicklung ein bisschen abgehängt worden sind, weil weder die Laptop- noch die Mobiltelefontechnologie in Europa gepusht worden ist, sondern das war eher Korea, Japan, im asiatischen Raum. Und die Batterietechnologie ist natürlich dort mitentwickelt worden, wo auch die Geräte selber ihre wesentlichen Standorte hatten.
Die Basis der Lithiumionenakku, die wir heute in all unseren Geräten haben, die kommt aus Europa. Das waren tatsächlich festkörperchemische Arbeiten, die in den 70er Jahren durchgeführt worden waren. Jetzt geht es mit den Traktionsbatterien fürs Auto wieder zurück. Weil die Autoindustrie zwar auch in Asien stark ist, aber auch in Europa und Deutschland. Das heißt, es wird jetzt wieder Kapazität aufgebaut und die Batterieforschung ist jetzt eines der wirklich heißen Gebiete in der Chemie Energietechnologieentwicklung. Und das erklärt es, warum man häufig neue Konzepte zu Gesicht bekommt. Wobei grundsätzlich viele der Konzepte bekannt sind.
Wie gesagt, die Metallluftbatterie gibt es kommerziell seit langen Jahren als Einwegbatterie. Aber den Schritt, sie mit wirklich großem Forschungsaufwand zu versuchen, wiederaufladbar reversibel zu machen, den hat man eben erst vor kurzer Zeit gegangen, weil für so einen kleinen Markt wie Hörhilfen, Hörgeräte, mit doch sehr kleinen Batterien, die da drin sind, da investiert man nicht den riesen Forschungsaufwand, den es bedarf, dieses ich sage mal elektrochemische Eisenentrosten, auf Batterietechnologie zu übertragen. Aber jetzt passiert das eben.
Die Speicherung, also Batterien sind ja jetzt nicht nur interessant für mobile Geräte, sondern es ist ja auch Teil des generellen Energieproduktionsumbruchs. Wir wollen alle gerne mehr aus Wind und Sonne, natürlich auch aus anderen naturnahen Produktionsquellen, Energie gewinnen. Haben aber immer das Problem, dass die Energie halt unter Umständen zu einem Zeitpunkt erzeugt wird, wo sie nicht gebraucht wird, ergo muss sie halt gespeichert werden. Klassische Systeme wie, Wasser auf den Berg pumpen, funktioniert zwar im Prinzip, aber die Anzahl der Berge, wo man noch Wasser draufpumpen kann ist halt auch begrenzt, die lassen sich ja nicht mal soeben produzieren. Ich schätze mal auch das dürfte ein sehr großer Fokus der Forschung sein, wo es nicht um Geräte geht, sondern einfach um die Speicherung von Energie für den Großeinsatz.
Ja, da geht es tatsächlich um Lösungen auf der Ebene Energiesystem. Und ich glaube, da sollte man zunächst einen Schritt zurücktreten. Sie haben zurecht gesagt, die Herausforderung ist es, mit dieser fluktuierenden Einspeisung, die aus Wind und Sonne kommt, umzugehen, weil eben der Wind nicht bläst und die Sonne nicht scheint immer dann, wenn wir viel Energie brauchen. Das heißt wir müssen zeitliche Verschiebung vornehmen können von elektrischer Energie. Da geht es ja im wesentlichen um elektrische Energie. Teilweise auch wirklich mal Flaute von vielleicht drei Wochen, so was passiert, überbrücken kann. Da ist Speicherung eine Lösung. Man muss systemisch sich immer angucken, was kann ich denn eigentlich machen, um da mit umzugehen.
Und da gibt es eigentlich insgesamt vier verschiedene konzeptionell verschiedene Möglichkeiten, mit dieser fluktuierenden Einspeisung umzugehen. Das eine ist eine stärkere Vernetzung. Im Moment wird elektrische Energie so typischerweise naja transportiert über Distanzen von maximal einigen hundert Kilometern. Das ist das, was man mit den typischen Wechselspannungs- Wechselstromleitungen gut schaffen kann, ansonsten werden die Verluste zu groß. Wenn man a) stärker vernetzt, b) über weitere Strecken transportiert, dann hat man schon mal einen Teil dieser Fluktuation ausgeglichen, denn wenn es an der Nordsee keinen Wind gibt, dann gibt es vielleicht in Südspanien und Portugal Wind.
Und wenn man eine Leitung hat, die die Nordsee oder Zentraleuropa mit Spanien, Portugal, Norwegen verbindet oder ein Netz hat, was diese Verbindung schafft, der griffige Term dafür ist eigentlich Europa auf der Kupferplatte. Also Strom kann ungehindert durch ganz Europa fließen, ohne dass wir Widerstände, Verluste oder ähnliches hätten, dann kann man schon vieles auffangen. Dann mittelt sich einfach diese zeitliche Schwankung durch die räumliche Durchschnittsbildung schon wieder ein bisschen weg. Das ist die erste Komponente, Netzausbildung. Die zweite Komponente ist schlichtweg, Reservekapazität zu schaffen. Ich kann ja für die was weiß ich 10% der Zeit, in der mir dann tatsächlich erneuerbare Energien fehlen, kann ich ja fossile Kraftwerke stehenlassen. Wenn ich 90% der Zeit regenerativ arbeite, 10% fossil arbeite, habe ich die CO2-Emission in erster Näherung um den Faktor 90% gesenkt.
Also bisschen fossiles CO2 als Backup kann man sich ja vielleicht durchaus leisten. Das Dritte wäre etwas was man Demand-Zeit-Managment nennt. Also die Einspeisung, die fluktuierend ist, durch ein gezieltes Abregeln von Verbrauchern zu balancieren. Das wird man sicherlich in der ersten Phase nicht machen, indem man zu Hause bei Ihnen den Kühlschrank oder die Kühltruhe runterfährt, durch eine Schaltung des Elektrizitätswerks, obwohl so was durchaus gedacht wird. Am Anfang wird man sicher an große Kühlhäuser ran gehen. Wenn man da mal eine Stunde lang nicht noch Energie im Netz hat. Wenn man eine Stunde lang bei einem großen Kühlhaus den Kompressor ein bisschen runterfährt, der die Kühlleistung bringt, dann geht die Temperatur vielleicht von -30 auf -29,5 Grad hoch, das macht den Gütern, die dort gelagert werden in der Regel nichts. Hilft aber dem Elektrizitätsversorger sehr, sein System stabil zu halten.
In der chemischen Industrie gibt es viele solcher Prozesse, die Energie verbrauchen, aber typischerweise konstant gefahren werden, weil sie dadurch effizient werden. Wenn man die so gestaltet, dass man die auch mit unterschiedlicher Leistung relativ einfach betreiben kann, hat auch da das Energiesystem was davon. Also Demand-Zeit-Managment drittes Element. Und das vierte Element, was man nutzen kann, ist Speicherung. Was mit den anderen ein bisschen zusammenhängt, denn eine Reihe von Speichertechnologien benötigen tatsächlich Reservekapazität. Wenn ich beispielsweise wenn ich genug Energie im Netz habe durch Elektrolyse. Also die Spaltung von Wasser durch elektrischen Strom, Wasserstoff herstelle. Dann müsste ich den ja, wenn ich ihn nachher wieder energetisch nutzen will, rückverstromen und da brauche ich dann entweder eine Brennstoffzelle oder eine Gasturbine. Also das erfordert schon auch wieder die Reservekapazität.
Die ich oben schon genannt hatte. Aber wie gesagt, diese Speicherung ist eine Option. Da haben Sie eben zurecht gesagt, heute ist das fast ausschließlich Pumpspeicherkraftwerke. Also in Zeiten von Energieüberschuss pumpen wir Wasser nach oben in ein Reservoire, in Zeiten von Energienachfrage lassen wir es durch eine Turbine wieder ab. Die schaffen irgendwas wie 70% Effizienz, also man kriegt relativ viel der Energie zurück. Die sind verhältnismäßig kostengünstig. Im Moment haben die tatsächlich aber ein wirklich betriebswirtschaftliches Problem, was vielen nicht so bewusst ist. Durch den Ausbau der Fotovoltaik. Das ist eigentlich fast paradox. Denn mit fluktuierender Einspeisung werden solche Systeme eigentlich dringender gebraucht, sie werden aber unattraktiver dadurch, dass Fotovoltaik da ist.
Die haben früher ihr Geld damit verdient, dass nachts, wenn niemand Elektrizität haben wollte, die Grundlastkraftwerke weiter gelaufen sind, also die Braunkohleatomkraftwerke gelaufen sind und dann wurde Wasser hochgepumpt. Mittags wenn der Strom richtig teuer war, weil keine Einspeisung zusätzlich da war, dann haben die ihr Wasser abgelassen und haben diesen teuren Strom verkauft. Und damit haben die sich gerechnet. Durch den Preisunterschied zwischen Nachtstrom und Tagesstrom. Der Mittagspeak im Preis ist aber mittlerweile weg, weil wir soviel Fotovoltaik haben, dass mittags eben viel Fotovoltaikstrom im Netz ist. Das heißt diese schönen Spitzenpreise erzielen die Pumpspeicherkraftwerke nicht mehr. Und deswegen wird es für die Betreiber von Pumpspeicherkraftwerken immer schwieriger Geld zu verdienen, obwohl wir sie eigentlich wirklich dringend bräuchten, aber wir haben kein gutes Geschäftsmodell.
Wir sind in einem Systemwandel, wo es im Moment für diese Speicher kein Geschäftsmodell gibt. Aber wie gesagt, diese Speicher sind da. Ist stehende Technologie kann man nutzen. In Deutschland haben wir bestimmt keine Standorte mehr. In den Alpen möglicherweise schon. In Norwegen gäbe es auch viele. Aber da brauchen wir natürlich auch wieder das Netz, was uns mit genügend Kapazität an Norwegen anbindet. Dann haben Sie eben gesagt, man kann Batteriespeicher nehmen. Möglicherweise ist das die Graswurzelbewegung, die ohne dass es groß kontrolliert wird, viel Speichertechnologie schafft. Weil viele Hausbesitzer mit Fotovoltaikanlage überlegen sich, naja soll ich mir denn nicht auch noch eine Batterie in den Keller stellen und meinen Überschussstrom nicht ins Netz einspeisen, sondern in meine Batterie einspeisen, so dass ich später also den Strom nicht für 26 Cent vom Versorger kaufen muss, sondern den nehme ich einfach aus meinem im Keller gespeicherten Aggregat.
Oder ich nehme den gespeicherten Strom aus meinem Batterieaggregat, was ich da stehen habe. Ich glaube, das könnten unter bestimmten Randbedingungen betriebswirtschaftlich sinnvolle Lösungen sein, volkswirtschaftlich ist das wahrscheinlich eine viel zu teure Lösung. Also wenn jeder seine teure Batterie im Keller stehen hat, das ist eigentlich eine sehr teure Speichertechnologie im Prinzip zu anderen. Dann ist es volkswirtschaftlich wahrscheinlich keine optimale Lösung. Wenn das aber betriebswirtschaftlich für jeden Solaranlagen-, für jeden Fotovoltaikbetreiber attraktiv ist, so wie die Vergütungsstruktur für Strom im Moment ist, naja dann haben wir vielleicht am Ende in jedem Keller eine Batterie stehen, die verteilt diese Speicherkapazität schafft.
Also Tesla, dieser …
Will sie verkaufen.
... innovative Autohersteller von Elektroautos, hat ja gerade so eine Batterie für das Heim auch vorgestellt. Also wird zumindest ein wenig gepokert in diese Richtung.
Ist eine Technologie die geht, und wie gesagt, wenn die Vergütungsstrukturen, so wie wir sie im Moment haben, bleiben, dann kann das etwas sein, was sich für den Fotovoltaikanlagenbetreiber tatsächlich rechnet. Aber man muss volkswirtschaftlich im Hinterkopf behalten, dass wir natürlich diesen Fotovoltaikanlagenbetreiber im Moment über die erneuerbare Energie Umlage über das System subventionieren. Und es rechnet sich für ihn nur deswegen, weil diese Subventionen da sind. Wenn man das System volkswirtschaftlich aus 30.000 Fußsicht optimieren würde, würde man wahrscheinlich zu einer anderen Lösung kommen. Und diese andere Lösung könnte die Herstellung von Wasserstoff sein. Das ist im Moment eigentlich auch noch viel zu teuer. Eben durch die Elektrolyse, wie ich es eben angesprochen habe.
Den Wasserstoff kann man in großen Kavernen speichern. Da gibt es Kavernen, die an Raffineriestandorten existieren und die den Wasserstoffbedarf der Raffinerie eben decken. Das sind 100.000e an Kubikmetern, ausgelaugt aus Salzstöcken. Die haben wir heute auch schon, die werden aber zu Erdgasspeicherung genutzt. Also wir haben in Deutschland so ein Viertel, ein Fünftel, bis ein Viertel des Jahresbedarfs an Erdgas können wir speichern unterirdisch. Also wir kriegen nicht konstant unseren Bedarf aus Russland und Norwegen über Pipelines. Sondern wir haben Speicherkapazität, die ungefähr ein Fünftel unseres Jahresbedarfs entspricht. Und ein Teil dieser Speicher sind genau diese aus Salz ausgelaugten 100e, 1000e Kubikmeter großen Kavernen, in die könnte man auch Wasserstoff einlagern und dann wenn man ihn braucht wieder herausholen.
Also es gibt viele mögliche Speichertechnologien. Welche sich am Ende durchsetzt wird ganz schwierig vorherzusagen sein. Ich vermute, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht die volkswirtschaftlich optimale Lösung werden, sondern es wird insgesamt ein Mix aus unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten, mit fluktuierender Einspeisung umzugehen, entstehen, der sich ja durch gesetzliche Rahmenbedingungen ergibt, der sich durch Marktbedingungen ergibt, der sich teilweise auch durch Zeit- und Pfadabhängigkeiten ergibt. Manche Dinge lohnen sich in einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, 10 Jahre später wird man es anders machen, aber dann hat man halt die Dinger da stehen und dann betreibt man sie halt weiter. Also das zu planen, wie ein System aussieht, was mit fluktuierende Einspeisung umgeht, ist extrem schwierig.
Wenn man alle Randbedingungen kennen würde, könnte man es wahrscheinlich tun. Man kennt aber nicht alle Randbedingungen und man hat vor allen Dingen viele Spieler im System, deren Verhalten nicht unbedingt vorhersehbar ist. Wie gesagt, Sie können nicht vorhersehen, wie viele der Fotovoltaikanlagenbesitzer sich eine Batterie in den Keller stellen werden, das weiß man schlichtweg nicht.
Der Markt scheint da überhaupt. Also was ich auch persönlich sehr beruhigend oder fast schon begeisternd finde ist, es sind einfach sehr viele neue Ideen in der Diskussion. Um nochmal an die Sache mit der Gasspeicherung anzuknüpfen, Power to Gas ist glaube ich auch so ein Buzzword, was in vielerlei Munde ist, zumindest so bei Technikern und politischen Entscheidern.
Was auch viele Schattierungen hat, das bedeutet nicht bei jedem das gleiche.
Ja also ich interpretiere das jetzt mal frei mit, man hat halt den Strom gerade irgendwie erzeugt, zum Beispiel eben aus Wind oder aus Sonne und da man ihn nicht sofort nutzen kann, erzeugt man damit Gase, die man dann halt nutzen kann, um sie in diesen existierenden Kavernen, in diesen künstlichen Hohlräumen unter den Städten zu speichern. Ist das ein realistischer Trend oder?
Ich habe ja gerade den Wasserstoff beschrieben. Das ist eigentlich der Grundschritt beim Power to Gas. Ich kann mir kaum einen anderen Power to Gas Schritt vorstellen, als der, wo man primär Wasserstoff erzeugt und aus elektrischer Energie Wasserstoff zu machen ist Power to Gas, denn der Wasserstoff ist ein Gas. Meist wird allerdings der Begriff Power to Gas in der öffentlichen Diskussion so verstanden, dass man Methan erzeugt, also den Hauptbestandteil von Erdgas. Das ist eigentlich die dominierende Idee in den Köpfen der meisten Menschen und dazu muss man vom Wasserstoff einen weiteren Schritt gehen, nämlich man muss irgendeine Kohlenstoffquelle haben. In machen Fällen diskutiert man da sogar CO2, in einem Audi-Modell-Projekt wird das zum Beispiel gemacht.
Und jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück zum Katalysator vom Anfang. Mit einem Katalysator kann man aus CO2 Wasserstoffmethan herstellen. Die wesentliche Komponente vom Erdgas und sie ins Erdgasnetz einspeichern. Das Methan, was man auf diese Weise herstellt, hat einen Preis, der jenseits von Gut und Böse liegt, im Vergleich zu fossilem Methan, was aus der Pipeline aus Russland kommt. Keiner sagt einem ganz genau, was das kostet, aber wenn man da mal so grobe Überschläge macht, dann kommt man schon mal auf einen Faktor 5-10 ungefähr.
Was macht das so teuer?
Die Anlagen kosten für den Elektrolyseur, man muss also das Aggregat haben, was aus elektrischer Energie und Wasser Wasserstoff herstellt. Die Elektrizitätskosten, die können zwar niedrig sein, wenn man Überschussstrom hat, aber selbst wenn sie null sind, was sie nur selten sind, hat man immer noch die Anlagenkosten. Also man ist eigentlich zwischen Skylla und Charybdis dabei, entweder lasse ich meine Anlage die ganze Zeit laufen, dann amortisiert sich die Anlage gut und meine Anlagenkosten, meine Investkosten kann ich auf einen breiten Zeitraum, auf einen langen Zeitraum umlegen. Dann kostet mich aber die elektrische Energie viel. Weil es eben nicht nur die Billigstromzeiten gibt. Oder ich elektrolysiere nur mit billiger elektrischer Energie, dann kann ich aber auch meine Anlagenkosten nur in einer sehr kurzen Zeit rein holen. Ich muss also meine Abschreibung auf sehr kurze Zeiten umlegen und dann wird es eben relativ teuer.
Und aus dieser Zwickmühle kommt man kaum raus. Also der Schritt ist teuer. Dann ist die Effizienz, man verliert bei jedem Schritt quasi Energie. Die Effizienz von Elektrolyseuren auf der Basis von so einer ganzen Anlage, naja die liegt im Moment vielleicht bei 60%, vielleicht kommt man ein bisschen weiter, aber am Ende in dem Wasserstoff hat man nur noch 60% des Energieinhalts des Stroms. Dann hat man die Anlage, um aus dem Wasserstoff das Methan zu machen, die kostet was. Die hat Energiekosten, um betrieben zu werden, vielleicht muss man sogar das CO2 bezahlen, wenn man Glück hat, kriegt man es umsonst, aber vielleicht muss man es ja sogar bezahlen, das ist unklar. Das addiert zu den Kosten. Naja und dann hat man das Methan, was mit dem Methan aus der Pipeline konkurriert, das ist dann verdammt teuer.
Und wenn man das Methan noch wieder zurückverstromt, ich würde es nicht tun. Ich würde es eher für die Wärmeerzeugung oder eine Erdgasheizung benutzen oder im Auto, aber wenn man es noch zurückverstromen würde, die besten Gasturbinen schaffen eine Methan zu Stromeffizienz von 60%. Das beste Gaskraftwerk, was wir haben, in Irsching??? das, was jetzt abgeschaltet werden soll, hat so diese Effizienz. Das heißt man verliert a) Energiegehalt über diese ganze Kette hinweg, b) jeder Schritt kostet. Und wenn man das zusammenlegt, dann sehe ich im Moment noch nicht, dass das ein tragfähiges Geschäftskonzept sein könnte. Im Moment wie gesagt würde sich selbst der Wasserstoff, den man so herstellt, nicht rechnen.
Aber wenn ich ein Gas machen würde, dann wäre mein Favorit der Wasserstoff, den würde ich in die Kaverne einspeisen und den würde ich auch nicht wieder rückverstromen, sondern auf die Kaverne würde ich eine Chemiefabrik setzen und den Wasserstoff chemisch nutzen, denn heute machen wir den aus Erdgas. Da würde ich also schlichtweg Erdgas substituieren durch diesen eingespeicherten Wasserstoff. Das scheint mir aus der 30.000 Fußhöhe das geschicktere Vorgehen zu sein.
Wenn man es nur in chemischen Anlagen nutzen kann, dann kann man ja sozusagen auch nur durch die Einsparung, was die chemischen Fabriken nicht mehr an Erdgas verwenden quasi einen Gewinn machen. Das ist keine allgemein nutzbare Energiequelle an der Stelle.
Es ist keine, es würde nicht eine Lücke im Elektrizitätsbedarf decken, den ich hätte, wenn ich drei Wochen Flaute habe. Das ist das was Sie meinen. Das stimmt, aber wie gesagt, diese Flauten kann man ja auch anders überbrücken. Durch ein Reservekraftwerk, was dann fossil laufen würde. Oder wenn ich diese Wasserstoffabnahme hätte, dann könnte man ja leichte Überschusskapazitäten für die Herstellung von regenerativem Strom machen, weil ich habe ja diesen Auslass in Richtung Wasserstoff. Wird möglicherweise nicht die Dimension haben, die man insgesamt braucht, aber es geht glaube ich nicht um eine einzige Lösung, sondern man braucht eine Verschaltung vieler verschiedener Optionen. Wie ich es eben angesprochen habe, alle vier wird man in irgendeiner Art und Weise brauchen und naja vielleicht werden wir am Ende für Langstrecken auch Hybridfahrzeuge haben, die eine Batterie für den Kurzstreckenbereich und eine wasserstoffbetriebene Brennstoffzelle für die längeren Reichweiten haben als Autos.
Dann habe ich da auch nochmal einen Auslass für einen Wasserstoff. Und ein Wasserstoffauto mit Brennstoffzelle ist zumindest dort wo chemische Energie in mechanische Energie umgesetzt wird, immer noch ungefähr doppelt so effizient, wie ein Verbrennungsmotor. Ein Verbrennungsmotor ist eben ein Aggregat, was im wesentlichen Hitze erzeugt und nicht Vortrieb.
Jetzt ist ja klar, hier müssen ja Fortschritte erzielt werden. Da sind wir uns glaube ich alle einig. Und sicherlich wollen die auch alle irgendwie erzielen. Aber um jetzt hier wirklich zu einem Ergebnis zu kommen, haben wir es derzeit glaube ich auf der einen Seite eben mit der reinen Forschung zu tun, die ihren Beitrag zu leisten hat. Haben es in gewisser Hinsicht eben mit dem Markt und den Zwängen, die eben zwischendurch auch schon anklangen zu tun. Und natürlich auch der Bereitschaft eines solchen Marktes, überhaupt erst mal in bestimmte Bereiche zu investieren. Und damit kommen wir dann auch gleich schon zum dritten Teil, nämlich der Politik oder der Gesellschaft insgesamt, die ja dann, wie zum Beispiel ja zumindest verkündet wird, durch eine Energiewende, solche Maßnahmen eben vorantreiben möchte.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wenn man es jetzt mal aus der Perspektive des Forschers sieht, welche Rolle spielt jetzt die Forschung allein hier in dieser Trinität. Und vor allem welche Möglichkeiten und Bedürfnisse gibt es, jetzt in die Gesellschaft, in die Politik auch aus der Forschung heraus zu wirken, um diesen Diskurs einfach mit voran zu treiben?
Ich bleibe zunächst mal eng bei der natur- und ingenieurwissenschaftlichen Forschung. Wird gleich noch ausweiten. Die naturingenieurwissenschaftliche Forschung hat mehrere Aufgaben in diesem Spiel. Das eine ist, Optionen bereit zu stellen, über die Politik und Gesellschaft später entscheiden können. Also so ein komplexes Gebilde, wie ein Energiesystem, sollte bestimmt nicht auf eine einzige Lösung setzen, denn wenn diese Lösung scheitert, braucht man Backup Lösungen. Braucht man zweit, dritt, viertbeste Strategien. Das heißt Optionen bereitstellen ist eine ganz wesentliche Funktion. Die zweite Funktion, die Forschung hat, ist, klarzumachen, was die Randbedingungen sind, denen bestimmte Technologien unterliegen. Also diese Energieverluste in der Wirkungsgradkette.
Deutlich zu machen und zu sagen, wenn du das machst, dann wird das die und die Folge haben. Oder klarzumachen, dass ein Bioethanol mit Weizen, ich glaube das war die Ukraine das Beispiel, ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau, faktisch die gleiche CO2-Emission hat pro gefahrenen Kilometer, wie ein Kraftstoff, der aus Erdöl hergestellt wird. Also Transparenz zu schaffen für die naturwissenschaftlichen Grundlagen. Von Entscheidungen, die wir über unser Energiesystem treffen. Oder zu sagen, naja wenn wir Fotovoltaikenergie von der Sahara nach Nordeuropa transportieren wollen, dann kann ich das nicht mit Wechselstromleitungen machen, sondern da brauche ich Gleichstromübertragungssysteme.
Oder wenn ich unter dem Meer durch möchte, brauche ich auch Gleichstromübertragungssysteme. Also diese Grundlagen klarzumachen ist eine weitere Funktion von Forschung. Wenn man dann weitet über den Bereich der natur- und ingenieurwissenschaftlichen Forschung hinaus, wo wir ich sage mal einfach nur Lösungsoptionen bereitstellen müssen, dann gibt es für mich auch, und auch das würde ich unter Forschung fassen, schlicht die Entwicklung auch von Konzepten, mit denen man neue Energiesysteme implementieren kann. Marktdesign, wie sollen eigentlich unsere Governmentsstrukturen??? auf Energiemärkten aussehen. Das ist vieles nicht bekannt, wie Wirkungen, bestimmte Eingriffe, bestimmter Maßnahmen sind.
Was brauche ich für rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen, um ein neues Energiesystem zu implementieren, was mit großen Anteilen fluktuierender Einspeisung umgehen muss.. Was sind eigentlich die Ansichten, Haltungen, Entscheidungen der Menschen, die in diesem System leben? Wie wirkt es sich aus, wenn Menschen die Chance haben, autark ihre Energie zu produzieren? Also ich habe eben dieses Beispiel Batterie plus Fotovoltaik angesprochen. Betriebswirtschaftlich rechnet sich das im Moment wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht. Ich habe gesagt, wenn überhaupt, dann rechnet es sich betriebswirtschaftlich wahrscheinlich nicht volkswirtschaftlich. Im Moment rechnet es sich wahrscheinlich nicht mal betriebswirtschaftlich. Trotzdem tun es Menschen, weil sie sagen, ich möchte nicht von großen Energieversorgern abhängig sein. Ich möchte meinen eigenen Strom produzieren.
Ist eine valide Position, muss man akzeptieren. Aber wie viele Menschen agieren so, das hat Einfluss auf die Entwicklung unseres Energiesystems und wir wissen darüber nicht allzu viel. Wir wissen auch nicht, wie man dieses möglicherweise beeinflussen kann. Das sind alles Fragen jenseits natur- und ingenieurwissenschaftlicher Forschung, die aber trotzdem von enormer Bedeutung sind.
Wer kann sich dieser Fragen annehmen oder sollte sich dieser Fragen annehmen oder nimmt sich der schon an?
Dieser Fragen sollten sich auch alle anderen Wissenschaften annehmen. Also Energieforschung ist keine rein ingenieur- oder naturwissenschaftliche Frage. Wenn man länger drüber nachdenkt stellt man eigentlich fest, dass fast jede Wissenschaft etwas beizutragen hat. Was ich lange Zeit selbst aus den Naturwissenschaften zumindest nicht auf meinem Radarschirm hatte, die Meteorologie hätte ich nicht als Energiewissenschaft identifiziert. Aber wenn Sie sich überlegen, wie wichtig es ist, dass ein Energieversorger weiß, wann ein Sturmfeld über Norddeutschland zieht und damit alle Turbinen entweder voll drehen oder abgeregelt werden müssen, dadurch wird die Meteorologie auf der Stelle zu einer ganz wesentlichen Energiewissenschaft. Und solche Fragestellungen gibt es in fast allen anderen Bereichen.
Aus den Sozialwissenschaften ist der Begriff des sogenannten Rebound-Effekts bekannt. Der ganz grob gesprochen bedeutet, dass ich Effizienzgewinne von energieverbrauchenden Systemen, was auch immer das ist, am Ende nicht 1:1 in einer Reduktion des Energieverbrauches niederschlagen. Ich nehme immer das sehr plastische und wahrscheinlich jedem eingängige Beispiel, warum so ein Rebound-Effekt auftritt. Da gibt es eine neue Kühlschrankgeneration, A+++, die brauchen fast gar keine Energie machen, sind super isoliert und diejenigen, die Energie sparen wollen, kaufen sich dann so einen Kühlschrank. Bauen den ein und den alten schmeißen sie nicht weg, sondern stellen den zum Bierkühlen in den Keller. So dann hat man eine super neue Energietechnologie, aber natürlich schlägt sich diese Einsparung nicht nieder in einer vergleichbaren Gesamteinspeicherung an Energie.
Die Kollegen aus der Soziologie gehen viele Aggregationsstufen höher und erklären auf einer ganz abstrakten Ebene diese Rebound-Effekte für mich auch eigentlich sehr plausibel dadurch, dass man durch niedrigeren Energieverbrauch ja Kosten spart, damit mehr Geld zur Verfügung hat und dieses Geld dann typischerweise nicht auf die Bank legt, sondern irgendwas anderes damit macht. In den Urlaub fliegt, sich ein Motorboot kauft. Und das sind alles Effekte, die oberflächlich verstanden sind, aber noch nicht wirklich verstanden sind. Und vor allen Dingen ist nicht klar, was machen wir denn eigentlich, um dem entgegen zu wirken. Wie schaffen wir es denn wirklich Effizienzgewinne in Energieeinsparung auf der Systemebene zu transformieren? Für mich sind diese Fragen politische Fragen, rechtliche Fragen, wirtschaftliche Fragen, Governmentsfragen??? sind eigentlich die größeren Hürden auf dem Weg zu einer Energiewende, als die technologischen und naturwissenschaftlichen Fragen.
Das ist an vielen Stellen müssen wir natürlich weiterkommen. Wir brauchen, wenn wir Autofahren wollen, so wie bisher, brauchen wir bessere Batterien, wenn wir das auf der Basis von Elektrofahrzeugen machen wollen. Wir brauchen bessere Fotovoltaikanlagen. Wir brauchen effizientere Wege, um elektrische Energie in Wasserstoff umzuwandeln. Alles technologische Fragen, die wir noch lösen müssen, aber die Hürden in den anderen Bereichen sind meiner Einschätzung nach höher. Und wenn Sie sich überlegen, kommen wir nochmal zurück zum Auto, da sage ich ja eigentlich immer, wir wollen mit dem Auto 600 Kilometer fahren. Man könnte ein anderes Mobilitätssystem haben. Man könnte den Langstreckenverkehr mit Zügen machen, die sowieso elektrisch betrieben und an jedem Bahnhof hat man in irgendeinem Hochhaus oder wie auch immer, ein Lager von Elektroautos, mit denen man die letzten 50 Kilometer bewältigt. Und die werden übers Handy einfach freigeschaltet. Also nur mal gesponnen.
Wie das teilweise schon ist mit Carsharing.
Wie das teilweise schon ist. Aber benutzen die Menschen das? Nein. Oder nur ganz wenige. 5%.
Ich habe das mal gemacht.
Ja, ich war früher auch Carsharer bevor wir Kinder hatten. Es benutzen natürlich Menschen, aber Verhaltensänderungen passieren auf einer Zeitskala, die angesichts der Herausforderungen vor denen wir wahrscheinlich stehen, zu lang sind. Also ich würde tendenziell immer versuchen, technologisch weiterzukommen und den Menschen mit besserer Technologie das zur Verfügung zu stellen, an was sie gewöhnt sind, als sie dazu zu bewegen, ihr Verhalten zu ändern. Weil das sind lange Skalen über die wir da reden. Und vielleicht ist es an manchen Stellen erforderlich, aber der Verkauf einer Energiewende mit der Nebenbemerkung, und wir müssen dann alle sehr asketisch leben, der ist nicht einfach. Also dann nehme ich lieber den Tesla, den Sie eben schon erwähnt haben und sage, das ist ein Elektroauto, super Fahrspaß und hat wenig CO2-Emission.
Das verkauft sich besser. Das werden wir nicht an jeder Stelle schaffen. Also wenn wir ein nachhaltiges Energiesystem entwickeln wollen, dann mag es an der einen oder anderen Stelle auch erforderlich sein, wirklich Verhalten zu ändern und Verhalten anzupassen. Und wir werden vielleicht dazu gezwungen werden durch den Klimawandel. Aber ich würde lieber an so vielen Stellen wie möglich Askese vermeiden und sagen, du kriegst die gleiche Dienstleistung nur effizienter und besser in Bezug auf Energieverbrauch.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht erfordert es vielleicht auch, vielleicht etwas überspitzt gesagt, neue Generation von Wissenschaftlern, aber zumindest ein Umdenken auch bei Wissenschaftlern, sich auch selber mehr in diesen gesellschaftlichen Prozess sich mit einzubringen. Sei es eben durch eine interdisziplinäre Vernetzung, um solche Fragen zu klären. Aber auch so in der Außenwirkung. Ich meine, anfangs hatten wir schon so dieses aufklärerische, junge Menschen begeistern für Wissenschaft, aber auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch genau an die Leute heran, die an anderen Stellen die Weichenstellungen vornehmen.
sie sind ja auch unter anderem, das muss man auch noch mal erwähnen, ausgezeichnet worden vom Stifterverband für die deutsche Wissenschaft, gerade auch, weil Sie da so übergreifend das Thema bearbeiten mit dem Kai Friedrich von Weizsäcker??? Preis letztes Jahr. Was wäre denn so Ihre Botschaft an die Wissenschaftler, wie man sich da selbst aufstellen muss in seiner Forschung, um einfach mehr in diese Richtung zu gehen?
Also zum einen würde ich erst mal sagen, es muss wahrscheinlich nicht jeder tun. Es gibt die Wissenschaftler, die hervorragend sind in ihren Labors und hervorragende Arbeit leisten, aber denen es vielleicht nicht so gegeben ist, nach außen zu wirken und dann ist das auch okay. Ich glaube aber, dass Wissenschaftler, dass wenn sie zumindest eine gewisse Sensibilität und Freude dafür und Freude daran haben, nach außen zu wirken, dass sie sich nicht scheuen dürfen, das dann auch zu tun. Wir sind als Wissenschaftler eigentlich immer trainiert auf höchste Präzision, auf jedes Bedenken, jedes Gegenargument gleich mitzudenken, gleich mit zu formulieren. Manchmal muss man in dieser Kommunikation in breitere gesellschaftliche Bereiche vereinfachen. Oder eigentlich muss man fast immer vereinfachen.
Und man sollte sicherlich nicht soweit vereinfachen, dass es falsch wird. Aber man sollte durchaus bereit sein, an manchen Stellen die absolute wissenschaftliche Präzision auch mal zu opfern, um den Punkt klar zu machen und um den Adressaten tatsächlich zu erreichen. Das fällt vielen Wissenschaftlern schwer. Das fällt auch mir oft schwer. Also sobald ich eine Aussage mache, fallen mir immer schon die drei Nebenbedingungen ein, unter denen eigentlich diese Aussage nur gültig ist. Aber wenn ich die bei jeder Aussage gleich mit nenne …
Verwirrt man ja auch.
Dann kommt man ja nicht weiter, dann erreicht man ja niemanden mehr. Also dieses Bemühen um eine einigermaßen einfache Sprache, das Bemühen ja nicht alle Randbedingungen noch mitzunennen, um wissenschaftlich absolut unangreifbar zu sein, das muss man aufbringen. Sonst wird man scheitern.
Kann es sinnvoll sein, diese Kommunikationsaspekte auch als Teil der Ausbildung zu verstehen und mehr einzubringen? Oder führt das schon zu weit?
Ich scheue mich davor, Ausbildung zu überfrachten mit immer neuen Aspekten. Also für einen Wissenschaftler finde ich es am Ende schon wichtig, dass er erst mal sein Handwerkszeug wirklich beherrscht. Also der Kernbereich der muss gewährleistet sein. Ich finde es gut, solche Dinge als Angebot mit zur Verfügung zu stellen. Also Wissenschaftskommunikation an Universitäten als Wahlfach beispielsweise zu haben. Wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es am Ende jedem gegeben sein wird und es ist auch nicht erforderlich, dass es jeder wirklich tut und in die Öffentlichkeit geht, in die breitere Gesellschaft versucht zu wirken, aber man muss die Chance haben, sich darin auszubilden.
Und die meisten Promotionsprogramme in der Chemie zumindest, die ich kenne, die haben immerhin schon Blöcke drin, wie Präsentationstechniken. Da geht es aber im wesentlichen um wissenschaftliche Präsentationen. Was mache ich auf einer Konferenz? Wie trage ich da vor? Ich meine, auch das ist wichtig. Kann man schon deutliche Unterschiede feststellen, wenn man auf eine Tagung geht. Dieser Aspekt, wie wirke ich nach außen, wie spreche ich vor einem allgemeinen Publikum bei Wissenschaft im Rathaus oder was auch immer, das wird in der Regel nicht gelehrt. Das als Angebot zu haben, finde ich wichtig. Verpflichtend würde ich so was nicht in Curricula integrieren. Das würde meiner Ansicht nach zu weit gehen, denn der Zeitaufwand, der für ein Studium zur Verfügung steht, ist limitiert und wie gesagt, mir wäre es nicht lieb, wenn alle Wissenschaftler sehr gut nach außen kommunizieren können, aber nicht mehr wissen, worüber sie kommunizieren.
Also der Kernbereich ist für mich die Pflicht. Der muss da sein und der muss beherrscht werden und dann kann man nach außen noch was rum gestalten. Und das kann unterschiedliche Aspekte haben und ein Aspekt wäre eben so ein Kommunikationsaspekt, den ich wichtig finde, aber ich würde den nicht verpflichtend für jeden machen.
Was vielleicht für die meisten Wissenschaftler nicht unbedingt gilt, aber für Sie sicherlich in so einer exponierteren Position als Direktor eines solchen Instituts wahrscheinlich schon eher, ist natürlich auch der Kontakt so in die politische Welt der Gesellschaft. Welche Erfahrungen haben Sie denn da gemacht? Insbesondere mit der Wahrnehmung der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit in der Politik. Ich meine, ich würde mal unterstellen, Wissenschaft erhält generell eine große Anerkennung und die Bedeutung auch als Basis der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung ist durchaus da in Deutschland, gar keine Frage, trotzdem dürften Sie ja auch noch weitere Einblicke gewonnen haben?
Also grundsätzlich nimmt man das was aus der Wissenschaft kommt erst, man hört zu. In der Politik gefällt es nicht jedem ,wenn wissenschaftliche Einsichten den eigenen Vorstellungen entgegen laufen. Das ist aber meist so, ob das jetzt wissenschaftliche Einsichten sind oder nicht, wenn etwas den eigenen Vorstellungen entgegen läuft, wird es immer schwierig. Auf der anderen Seite wissenschaftliche Einsichten sind häufig tatsächlich fundamental, gegen die Thermodynamik kann man nicht anargumentieren, die gilt. Und da kommt man nicht raus. Und wenn man Vorstellungen hat, die den ersten Hauptsatz in der Thermodynamik, dem ersten Hauptsatz der Thermodynamik widersprechen, dann wird man damit scheitern.
Also das mag mancher eben nicht ganz gerne hören. Grundsätzlich ist meine Erfahrung aber, dass man zuhört. Ich teile nicht das Schimpfen vieler Teile unserer Bevölkerung auf Politiker, dass die nur an ihre eigenen Interessen denken. Die meisten Politiker, die ich kennengelernt habe, bemühen sich um Lösungen. Da mag man politisch manchmal nicht übereinstimmen mit den Positionen, aber die Politiker, die ich kenne, bemühen sich um Lösungen für wirklich komplexe Probleme und ich bewundere es, in wie viel verschiedene Themen die sich ja in kürzester Zeit jeweils eindenken müssen. Und am Ende auch noch so was wie Konsens schaffen müssen. Man kann ja die beste und richtigste Erkenntnis haben, wenn man nicht mindestens 50,1% der Menschen dafür gewinnt, auf welchem Wege auch immer, steht man mit dieser Erkenntnis da, ohne sie umsetzen zu können.
Also der Job, den die machen, ist schwierig und wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse sind ein Strang, der in diese Arbeit einfließt. Dieser Strang wird aufgenommen, diese Information wird mit berücksichtigt, aber es ist eben nicht die einzige Randbedingung, der man gehorchen muss. Nur wie gesagt, am ersten Hauptsatz der Thermodynamik kommt keiner vorbei. Also man wird nicht langfristig ein Energiesystem aufsetzen können, was diese Grundprinzipien nicht berücksichtigt. Die Randbedingung ist eine harte. Und es gibt andere Randbedingungen, die hart sind, aber dann gibt es eben auch weichere Punkte.
Und so für Ihr Heimatfach die Chemie, welche Herausforderungen sehen Sie da in der nächsten Zeit? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt viel über die Energiespeicherung gesprochen, das ist natürlich ein großes Thema.
Das ist eine super interessante Frage. Ich bin jemand, der auch in der Chemie in der Community viel unterwegs gewesen ist und gesagt hat, ihr müsst euch auch diesen Fragen öffnen. Energiespeicherung, Energiebereitstellung, Verteilung, ist ein brennendes Problem, da muss die Chemie ihren Beitrag leisten. Wir können große Beiträge leisten. Auf der anderen Seite ist eine Wissenschaft, die sich nur als Löser für Probleme betrachtet, die wird irgendwann ihren wissenschaftlichen Kern verlieren. Die wird Dienstleister für andere sein. Also die Wissenschaften müssen ihre wissenschaftsimmanenten großen Fragen haben. Ich sage mal, Faustsche Erkennen was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält. Das muss jede Disziplin haben.
Wenn eine Disziplin diese wissenschaftsimmanente Frage, die disziplinimmanente Frage nicht mehr stellt, dann ist das Ende der Disziplin vorprogrammiert und deswegen glaube ich schon, dass die Chemie auch ihre eigenen Fragestellungen suchen muss. Für mich die faszinierendste chemische Fragestellung hat mit Energie überhaupt nichts zu tun. Ist die nach dem Ursprung des Lebens. Woher kommt Leben? Wie ist Leben in die Welt gekommen? Ist eine rein chemische Fragestellung. Solange die Chemie nicht das hervorgebracht hat, was irgendwann mal leben wird, kann die Biologie nicht anfangen. Der Ursprung des Lebens ist eine chemische Fragestellung. Ist für mich die größte Fragestellung, die wir haben. Das wissen wir nicht, wie das Leben in die Welt gekommen ist.
Da hängen viele anderen Fragestellungen mit zusammen, aber wenn ich eine einzige formulieren sollte für die Chemie, das ist meine Jahrhundertfrage.
Die muss geklärt werden. Sollte.
Ob die geklärt werden muss, da kann man lange drüber streiten.
Das wäre ein erstrebenswertes Ziel.
Aber ich finde für uns als Menschen glaube ich, die wir Leben sind, ist das eine Frage, die interessiert mich als Mensch interessiert mich die Frage, wie kommt Leben in die Welt. Was ist Leben, was ist der Ursprung davon? Genau wie die Physiker die Frage haben, warum kennen wir nur 10% der Masse des Universums, der Rest ist dunkle Masse, dunkle Energie. Da kann man sich auch fragen, muss man das wissen? Naja natürlich muss man das nicht wissen, um bis zu seinem Tod hier auf dieser Welt existieren zu können. Aber diese grundsätzlichen Fragestellungen sind es doch, was Wissenschaft irgendwann ausgelöst hat.
Ja man weiß ja auch nicht, was letzten Endes dann darauf folgt, in dem Moment, wo man es herausgefunden hat. Da kann ja auch schon wieder alles ganz anders sein.
Da kann alles wieder ganz anders sein, aber diese Frage nach der Folge, nach der möglichen Nützlichkeit, ich glaube das ist nicht die Triebkraft von Wissenschaft. Die Triebkraft von Wissenschaft ist das, was der Höhlenmensch schon im Kopf hatte, als er in den Himmel guckte und sich gefragt hat, was sind das eigentlich für leuchtende Punkte da oben. Diese reine Neugier, zu verstehen, was um uns herum passiert, ist glaube ich eine der Grundtriebkräfte für Wissenschaft. Das ist für mich Wissenschaftler Kulturleistung. Wenn ich auf das Periodensystem gucke, ich habe in meinem Büro eine ganz bunte Version hängen, grafisch ganz toll gestaltet, dann sitze ich da manchmal vor, schau auf dieses Periodensystem und bin wirklich ja fasziniert und fast ehrfürchtig vor dieser kondensierten Kulturleistung, die darin steckt, die Elemente auf diese Art und Weise zu ordnen.
Die Grundprinzipien der Reaktivitäten in diesem Periodensystem wiederzugeben. Ich habe häufig schon zumindest halbernst, nicht wirklich nur im Scherz, darüber nachgedacht, dass eigentlich das chemische Periodensystem zum Weltkulturerbe erklärt werden sollte. Weil ich glaube, dass Wissenschaft ein ganz wesentlicher Teil unserer Kultur ist. Kultur ist nicht nur Musik, Gemälde, bildende Kunst. Wissenschaft ist ganz wesentlicher Teil unseres kulturellen Erbes. Und das ist jenseits jeder Nützlichkeitserwägung. Dass es schön ist, wenn die Dinge dann auch nützlich sind, naja gut. Unser ehemaliger Präsident Peter Gruß hat das immer so formuliert, die Max-Planck-Wissenschaft ist erkenntnisgeleitet, aber anwendungsoffen. Das finde ich eine wunderbare Beschreibung für das, was Wissenschaft in vielen Bereichen sein sollte.
Ja ich denke so ist es auch hier mit diesem Podcast, kann ich dazu sagen, und ich bedanke mich sehr für das Gespräch Herr Schüth.
Gerne.
Und ja ich bedanke mich auch natürlich wieder bei allen, die hier zugehört haben und sage, tschüss und bis bald, bis zum nächsten Mal.